what's going on guys I am standing
outside of Hall age Comic Con 2015 the
Warner DC panel just happened major news
trailers we're gonna bring you instant
reactions we had men on the inside and
the end and we're gonna talk to people
to find out here comes I'm here with
Andy signor and Dan Merle they were
inside Hall age for the DC panel I'm
jealous
okay so did you like it well you know we
hate DC right so no I loved it he
doesn't like he's the power to wipe out
the entire human race we have to stop
them like God get the conflict and I'm
on board and this Batman it's one I
think just from what we've seen it's the
one that we haven't really seen
on-screen yet which is the mean cruel
Batman which he can be in the comics
like you see of the shot of the thug who
has a bat branded on him and this is a
legitimate threat to Metropolis and the
big reveal that Zack Snyder dropped at
the panel was that in this universe
Gotham and metropolis are basically
neighbors he made it clear he's like you
go into metropolis because that's where
the higher end lives and so Gotham is
the lower end and it's like I'm kind of
okay with that I think that's interest
it's creating a good explains it in
their own world and if they can sell
this one and this movie works
DC's finally I think in a really good
shot to then to create this universe
there's a shot at the end of the
Superman Batman trailer that's he rips
the doors off the Batmobile and then
Batman just stands up out of the
Batmobile they just face off and like
I'm sorry I was 5 years old once that
was awesome I love that I love that's
why we watch this he wasn't in the suit
he was in the Batman suit he was and it
was cool seeing how Batman
he's actually pissed off with Superman
as a great legitimate reason to be that
was the emotional core of that trailer
and I think it's going to be awesome in
the movie
the little reveals that people aren't
expecting you're having kryptonite Zod's
body playing a huge factor and probably
leading to other things just little
easter eggs and you're smart enough to
notice you'll see the screens they had
were amazing did you hear about this
where they had these work screens that
went around the whole entire hall
instead of just the front and like like
360 pretty much any Easter eggs I
actually didn't notice it but in the in
the Superman some of my fan would caught
it it was a Robin suit that someone had
spray-painted there was a like a old
Robin suit that had stuff written on it
maybe referencing
big right center Jason Todd and my party
passed away how was the Suicide Squad
trailer it was at first when I first saw
the trailer while back and heard about
it I don't think it'd be that cool and
then seeing them all was dope especially
Will Smith they look crazy good I'm not
gonna lie
even Jai Courtney yes Steve and I air
came out and really like dropped all
these bombs like he was really like sort
of like a Marvel fan boys suck on this
like it was I like that I liked it so
they were they were throwing down
he was like yeah there's always good and
bad good bad but now it's time for bad
versus evil what was the loudest moment
in in that room when Jared Leto did the
Joker laughs like the audience was into
it the Joker shows up on at the very
very very end and you know he seemed
very lechery to me which is not
necessarily a bad thing his light of the
trailer was I'm not gonna kill you I'm
just gonna hurt you really really bad
they're taking it a new direction
very true to the comic books it looks
like so this is the next badass Joker I
kind of like that better than the Batman
person it's just cuz we haven't seen
anything from Zeus quite yet and so here
come on you want something big and new
most mind-blowing moment of the whole
panel most mind-blowing moment of the
whole panel probably would be seeing
that they announced Green Lantern as a
Green Lantern fan and not just being
Green Lantern based on earth but I want
to see Green Lantern in space doing what
he does best because there's no need for
a like movie to be based on earth we
didn't find out who plays Green Lantern
no we didn't find out who plays free
Lantern I thought that they would have
said something about Chris pine or
Tyrese or all the stuff that's been
going around but sadly we didn't get any
news today the Batman versus Superman
trailer did it were you satisfied it
definitely did it justice whoo that is
it for live reactions tomorrow we are
going to show you our live comic-con
movie fights and then next week huge
Comic Con coverage stay tuned thank you
for watching I'm al Rudnick bye-bye